morning Elaine good morning to you Nora
this painting was painted by Gilbert
Stuart at the end of George Washington's
presidency it is the only artifact still
in the white house that was here when
John Adams became the first president to
move in in 1800 it is significant that
it hangs here because so much history
continues to be made in the East Room
President Trump has already talked to
the press eight times here the latest
chapter in this room's storied past
Judge Gorsuch has outstanding legal
skills for more than 200 years the East
Room has played host to history
it's the largest room in the White House
it has the highest ceiling of any room
in the White House
so you see events of all kinds that take
place in this room
it's where Lyndon Johnson changed the
way US law handles issues of race in
1964 President Johnson signed the Civil
Rights Act he turned around and had this
wonderful warm handshake with dr. King
and where President Nixon said goodbye
to his staff as he resigned in 1974
aurevoir will see you again good evening
it was in the East Room where President
Obama announced to the world that Osama
bin Laden was dead the United States has
conducted an operation that killed Osama
bin Laden
it's grandeur today is in stark contrast
to the way it was first used Abigail
Adams hung laundry here here's the First
Lady of the United States has strung a
clothesline
from wall to wall and is hung the
president's laundry in there to dry the
East Room doubles as a music venue where
hundreds of artists have performed for
and sometimes with the president
[Music]
you have to look at it as sorry veterans
soul man Sam Moore has performed for six
presidents he says the East Room is one
of the few places where it's easy to put
politics aside when I see Republicans
and Democrats in the same room and
they're checking each other's hand and
hugging one another
behind the performance that's Wow the
room has been the site of marriages a
high school prom even presidential
funerals a versatility that makes it one
of the most important in the world there
are billions of people around the world
and they know what that house represents
is the symbol of freedom and democracy
there's so many of events that they're
familiar with take place right there in
the East Room when President Lincoln was
in the White House he hosted so many
dances that the staff had to prop up the
floor from the basement with extra wood
to prevent it from collapsing Gail yeah
it's incredible think about that seven
presidential funerals here seven wedding
ceremonies it's just such an incredible
room the largest in the White House and
no CBS this morning live yeah really
honored seriously thank you very much
shilling